- [Reporter] President Biden has nominated
Judge Ketanji Brown Jackson
to the Supreme Court,
- Good afternoon.
- the first black woman
nominated to be a justice
on the nation's highest court.
If confirmed, she would
replace Justice Stephen Breyer,
a liberal member of the court
who announced his retirement in January.
Judge Jackson served as a law clerk
to Justice Breyer earlier in her career.
- I've been a federal
judge for eight years
and I have a duty of independence.
I clerked for three federal
judges before I became a judge
and they were models of
judicial independence,
and what that has meant
is that I know very well
what my obligations
are, what my duties are,
not to rule with partisan
advantage in mind.
- What makes her a
strong nominee, in part,
is that professional diversity.
This sort of allows Biden
to fulfill a promise
that he's made to diversify the court,
not just by putting people in the court
who might have a different
demographic background,
who might look different,
but people who might also
just bring a different kind of experience.
Another thing that makes
her a strong nominee
is that she was just recently
confirmed to the DC Circuit,
and so it means that she's gone
through the Senate confirmation process.
- [Reporter] The president
made his decision
after meeting with the candidates,
studying their histories and case records,
and consulting legal experts,
the White House said.
- Although we have a pretty
closely divided Senate,
we think she still probably
has a pretty smooth path
to confirmation.
Vice President Harris
casts the deciding vote
and gives Democrats the majority.
- [Reporter] Mr. Biden's nomination
won't change the balance of power
on a conservative high court,
that is six justices appointed
by Republican presidents,
including three by former
President Donald Trump.
Judge Jackson currently serves
on the US Court of Appeals
for the District of Columbia Circuit,
one of the nation's
most influential courts
and often a stepping stone
for Supreme Court justices.
She joined the court last June
after spending eight years
as a federal trial judge
in the nation's capital.
- So President Biden has promised
to diversify the federal judiciary
in terms of both demographic background
and professional diversity,
and Judge Jackson ticks
both of those boxes.
She'll be the first
black woman on the court
and she also brings a background
as a criminal defender,
which we have not seen
in many, many years.
- I would say that my different
professional background
than many of the Court of Appeals judges,
including my District Court background,
which will be different, if I'm confirmed,
than many of my my
colleagues, would bring value.
It's sort of like the
Oliver Wendell Holmes quote,
that "The life of the law is
not logic; it's experience."
And so I've experienced life
in perhaps a different way
than some of my colleagues
because of who I am,
and that might be valuable.
I hope it would be valuable if
I was confirmed to the court.
- Republicans have tried to pin her down
on this question of the,
quote-unquote, living Constitution,
the idea that constitutional
interpretation
should adapt to social change,
should evolve over time.
She had said in 2013 at
a confirmation hearing
for the District Court that
she disagreed with that.
But more recently,
at her Appeals Court confirmation hearing,
she really just declined to talk about it
and deferred to the Supreme Court.
- The Constitution is
an enduring document.
It has, the Supreme Court
has said, a fixed meaning,
that we are to look to the original words
in the Constitution and interpret,
as lower court judges,
we interpret provisions
the way in which the Supreme Court does,
and they look at the text and meaning.
- Judge Jackson has not said very much
about what kind of a presence
she will be on the court,
as is common with lower court judges.
We don't know very much about
her judicial philosophy,
and when she was asked about it
at a recent confirmation hearing,
she really declined to
talk very much about it
and deferred to the Supreme Court.
- I think that I would
like to be remembered
as a judge who was both careful
and thorough in my opinions.
- [Reporter] It remains unclear
exactly when Judge Jackson's
confirmation hearings
will begin, but New York
Senator Chuck Schumer
said they will take place
in the coming weeks.